hi this is Marco clusky from Wired
magazine and I'm here with Jeff Weber
the designer of Herman Miller's new in
body chair and Jeff I want to talk to
you a little bit about how you go from
an idea to a finished chair the chair
again it's attempting to mimic or it is
I like to describe it it is the analog
of the human body and the spine the
human spine is incredibly intelligent
and complex our goal is to improve the
overall condition of the worker the
sedentary worker we determined that we
can in fact improve a person's health
via the design of a chair the body chair
actually does in fact improve the
person's health and it does that the
reducing constraints of blood flow
lowering the heart rate and allowing the
chest cavity to open up it instills a
level of movement that that no other
seating product includes and so movement
is certainly the key to good health we
would like to motivate people to work in
a more passive position from time to
time which means that they have the
ability to recline in this chair and
maintain that level of interface with
their technology it's beneficial
actually to sort leaned back in the
chair from time to time it's extremely
beneficial it doesn't mean that you're
loafing